chronic disability all right we're
coming in to go live now to these
pictures
uh of course that much anticipated
flight virgin galactic's flight sub
sub orbital flight uh with richard
branson on board these are
live pictures you can see there now uh
the space plane the white knight
aircraft vms eve
uh dropping off to carry the
rocket-powered spaceship the vss
unity continuing on that rocket power
you can see it there uh taking off it's
going up uh exceeding three g's or three
times the force of earth's gravity
it's going to continue climbing to
sub-orbital space
uh there'll be about three to four
minutes of weightlessness
at that point of course richard branson
virgin galactic's chief
is on board making this a very important
moment
for space tourism for space travel i
guess
can reach a max altitude of 88
kilometers above the earth
uh this is one of the final test
missions
before it aims before virgin galactic
aims to start commercial space tourism
next year
three two one release release release
clean release ignition
good rocket motor burn
there's mach one trimming now
the pilots are now unlocking the feather
and
as soon as they do that it's going to
initiate a backflip for spaceship unity
this is normal we want those windows
pointed down towards the earth to
maximize that incredible view
so feather is coming up now and the
pilots are also enabling
the rcs or reaction control system which
is what they'll use to control the
attitude of the vehicle while we're
outside the atmosphere
all right feather is all the way up we
are at about 250
000 feet now and climbing as soon as we
cross the boundary to space we'll hear a
word from our founder
sir richard branson
welcome to space unity 22.
so if you've uh if you're just joining
us that is a
virgin galactic suborbital flight
with uh founder richard branson
on board they are exceeding
uh three times the force of earth's
gravity to
rocket uh above the atmosphere reaching
a max
altitude of 88 kilometers
above the earth let's go to
and we'll be sure to capture his magical
words and share them with the world when
they're available
we reached apogee 282 thousand feet
remember the day remember where you are
and remember who you shared this with
and remember the name
virgin galactic because today space is
virgin territory the culmination of a
life's work
more than a half a century since the
world rejoiced in and was transformed by
humans leaving planet earth
sir richard branson fulfills his
long-held dream of experiencing space
with his crew congratulations again
richard and congratulations also to
seresha and colin on becoming astronauts
today
and welcome back to space to dave mike
and beth
oh you can see him now
so we are on the re-entry portion of our
flight now
and the mission specialists are heading
back to their seats
our training team has worked really hard
on this portion of the flight to make it
very natural and intuitive for
passengers
now when we talk about space travel a
lot of people know and expect the boost
portion of the flight to be
loud and thrilling but what's
interesting is re-entry is also very
similar
as supersonic air is flowing over the
vehicle in the feathered configuration
shock waves form on top of the cabin
which are audible to those inside
and for those of you on site watching on
the ground you should be able to hear a
double sonic boom as spaceship unity
once again breaks the sound barrier
okay some incredible live pictures there
uh
they're coming from virgin galactic's
feed of that sub-orbital
uh flight above the earth with virgin
galactic's richard branson
on board it's one of the final test
missions before
branson hopes to start commercial space
tourism next year let's uh speak to alan
boyle who is a contributing editor at
geekwire
uh who is joining us from seattle by
skype so just run us through what we've
just been hearing there
so we're now on the re-entry portion of
this flight
that's correct uh that they did have the
engine burn for full duration and so
uh you can uh the on-flight in-flight
video even shows
folks uh floating in zero-g and so this
is the
highlight of the ride is to get a view
of the curving earth and to
spend a few minutes in weightlessness
get out of your seats and uh
and do uh do a roll which apparently
they're doing so this is the big this is
the big moment
this is it yeah kind of um frustrating
that the images
i mean as would be expected the images
from inside the cabin
a little distorted yeah going at speeds
and then that far above
above the earth you would expect as much
i mean just
really incredible images what what are
these guys going to be experiencing
up there i mean you would imagine the
views would be incredible
the speed must feel quite unusual if
you're not used to
going up on a rocket ship
right uh so it's a few minutes of
weightlessness uh it's not an orbital
flight but it's pretty thrilling and the
view is fantastic you
you can see the terrain beneath you
the slight curve of the uh of the earth
and the black sky of space above and so
that's what people are going to pay
you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars to see
and then they have to quickly get back
into their seats they're probably doing
that right now
and experience a few g's of acceleration
on the way down
and so it's it's like a roller coaster
ride the really best part is at the top
of the ride but there are some thrills
to be had
on the way up and on the way down as
well and so they're getting ready for
the glide back to spaceport america
it's an up and down flight they are
staying in the same area it's not as if
they're going anywhere but this could be
the beginning
of a type of travel that will get people
places faster than ever
the re-entry uh coming back down to land
this isn't uh you know
the landing i was i was reading is going
to be much like
a plane a kind of a very soft landing
can you can you run us through what the
landing is like
well it's really a glider landing that
uh
the spaceship one rocket plane is
designed so that
it actually tilts its wings uh during
the descent
uh in a way that uh decelerates
the plane from supersonic speeds and
then
it straightens out its wings and becomes
a glider and then
takes a circling flight down it takes
maybe about 20 minutes or a half an hour
to get back to land
but it's very much like an airplane
landing
and from all evidence it looks as if
the gliding part of it is proceeding
just
according to norm and so they've really
been through the roughest part of the
flight and uh
it's all gravy from here all right thank
you very much for that alan boyle there
contributing editor at geekwell let's go
to rob reynolds
uh who is live at the virgin galactic
spaceport in sierra county
new mexico and rob we've had that that
that
high point i guess you like everything
seems to be going off without a hitch
flawlessly uh folly at the moment
everything seems to be as you say going
off
absolutely perfectly the separation went
uh went flawlessly then the the engine
burned
bringing uh the unity spacecraft up near
to space
88 kilometers above the surface of the
earth
that went perfectly well just about uh
30 seconds ago we heard that double
sonic boom
that the announcer on the virgin
galactic's live stream
mentioned uh which we carried on our air
uh and
we heard it off to the to the east in
that direction so
um it is uh now uh as
your guest was saying sorry rob we're
just gonna hold you there we're gonna
listen to richard branson on the
re-entry let's just hear what he's got
to say
and just like that he's gone that's
right i'm so happy we can catch a little
technical issues with uh with
broadcasting from sub-orbital
space i guess i can sympathize i can
sympathize with uh poor mr branson
because
i've had my share of audio problems as
well over the
over time but they're having a little
trouble with the the live feed but
everything else the important stuff is
going
very very well from everything that we
can see right now
um and while uh the the
the uh cameras on board might not be
working perfectly
that that's just a detail in terms of
the flight itself
but certainly uh i can guarantee you
that richard branson will have
plenty to say as soon as he gets his
feet back down on earth
yeah i mean he's got a there's quite
obviously a lot of planning has gone
into this
um this is a big i guess pr marketing
moment
i thought it was quite interesting the
commentators saying space is now
virgin territory i mean you know they
had they had a lot of board meetings to
decide on what they were going to say
and
that's what they they came to a lot of
this you know there is this this race
isn't there
this billionaire race
there is a big billionaire race and you
know branson uh
moved up his uh um
this this flight uh and then said
oh by no means was it in any way
uh intended to upstage jeff bezos who's
gonna go up
uh in his rocket on the 20th of july and
if you believe that i've got some
property on the planet jupiter that i'd
like you to
have a look at there's a lot of ego
involved here as well as a lot of
a lot of uh money and i think that
certainly uh
branson uh being that more i think of
that
of that showman that that kind of uh
public figure exuberant public figure
more so than jeff bezos who's
really uh you know a technocratic type
of figure and a
and a ceo businessman of course with an
enormous business empire that really
dwarfs richard branson's
but branson is is really good at this
kind of showmanship
bezos maybe not so much but bezos is
going to have his time too he'll have
his moment
on the 20th and i'm sure that uh with
him
bringing on board his brother
uh and bringing on board uh wally funk
who you mentioned a short while ago
uh that's gonna be uh touching i think
that'll that'll be some very emotional
territory there
so we'll see how that goes um and then
we'll see what what elon musk can pull
out of his hat another showman
with with a reputation for a lot of
surprises we all remember that
uh capsule there that that rocket ship
that headed off to mars with the david
bowie song
playing uh in the in in the cockpit so
uh uh musk has yet to
uh unveil his uh his big show
but this is really yeah it's kind of uh
like three really rich
uh uh barnum and bailey
kind of showman uh doing their thing in
space
and uh it's definitely captured the
attention of so many people around the
world
yeah in a not dissimilar way i guess
to those first those early space flights
by people like yuri gagarin and john
glenn people are
are interested they want to see this
work and they want to see
how it might affect them in the future
yeah i guess it's capturing the
imagination isn't it
um i was i was interested uh rob because
branson is a keen environmentalist
he arrived to the flight on his bike but
you'd think that
space flight would would be pretty bad
on the old
carbon footprint front
well yeah quite
it it does require a lot of
fuel to be expended it's not necessarily
the type of fuel that we use in our in
our vehicles
uh or in jet planes uh but nevertheless
it does create a lot of combustion and
that
is a factor definitely in in uh
uh global warming but um you know
some of the things that that elon musk
has said
have has kind of kind of
lent itself to the idea that maybe space
is the place for the human race
i'm not trying to make a poem here folly
maybe space is the place for the human
race to
go if our planet becomes uninhabitable
due to our own activities now you know
that
one could one could uh argue uh another
side to that
but uh yes uh there's definitely
i can hear i can hear planes in the air
now
i'm not sure oh i think it's yeah you
must almost be able to see it it looks
like it's coming down
to land and it has landed it's down
that's it that's it it's landed yes
that's right
it's down it's down perfectly and it's
going along
the the the runway coming to a stop now
looks like everything went just picture
perfect folly
um and people are applauding here yeah i
mean it's
it's it's it's just an important moment
it's quite incredible
you know you think about space flight uh
and the re-entry
space flight you don't think well you
don't imagine i didn't anyway that that
um
that said craft would come down and land
like any other aircraft your standard
aircraft but there we are
um talk me through the the the fanfare
surrounding this right
we're used to them landing in the ocean
or at baikonur cosmodrome
exactly talk me through the fanfare
because branson has said that he was
going to make some sort of announcement
after this didn't he
right he said he'd have a big surprise i
don't know what it is
he's got something up his sleeve
obviously i i i
haven't got richard branson's ear at the
moment but we'll find out pretty soon as
soon as they
uh get checked out of their their
spacecraft and then there will be a
a press conference they'll tell us about
what they experienced how they felt
about it
what their thoughts and feelings were i
mean this has got to be
a life-changing experience uh in in a
way
i think you know um remember that the
the
the people who went to the moon in the
apollo program some of them really were
changed
forever they they had spiritual
experiences
uh up there uh some of them were more
technocratic and did not but
but uh this has got to be something that
uh is is is very powerful for the human
mind
rob um branson is is obviously very
confident that that commercial space
tourism
uh is not that far away so confident in
fact he's already sold
seats for commercial flights not cheap
though
right 600 seats
talk me through that i mean that how
much do they cost willing to pay a
quarter of a million dollars
each right it's an incredible amount of
money
well before today they cost
they cost 250 000 each now maybe after
today
uh you know this could be a marketing
opportunity and the price could go
up but we have been told by virgin
galactic the company
that there's a uh a list of people
600 people so far who have uh
uh indicated that they will pay that
amount of money to put some money down
to
to make a space flight several years ago
here when there was a test flight i
spoke to
one of those people uh she was a a woman
from uh the united arab emirates and was
very
uh excited about the prospect i said
this is gonna be years from now
she said i don't care uh this is
something i wanna do and
and you know i'm willing to spend the
amount of money to have this personal
experience
it's also it's also a lot cheaper than
interesting to see if this
it's a lot cheaper than the 28 million
dollars that an unknown
mystery person has bid to fly with bezos
so um so yeah i mean it's it's very
expensive
not as expensive as that i will get you
to stand by for us
rob just to recap if you've just joined
us here on al jazeera uh what you're
looking at live pictures from sierra
county where we have seen
richard branson a virgin galactic take a
sub-orbital flight
uh above the earth where they had a few
minutes of weightlessness
this is virgin galactic taking its first
fully crewed flight to the edge of space
on board they had six people in total
two pilots four mission specialists of
which it richard branson
was one uh although they they could have
reached a max
altitude of 88 kilometers the world
governing body
puts outer space at 100 kilometers at
earth so there's a little tussling about
whether
this qualifies as space uh this
was uh the space plane took off attached
to a specially designed
aircraft the vms eve which carried the
rocket-powered spaceship the vss
unity after reaching
50 000 feet the plane was released and
dropped for a moment
then the rocket rocket ignited and then
the unity
climbed to sub-orbital space
before making its re-entry which was
very smooth indeed